in the last few years especially
whenever there is a weather event of any
sort it gets blamed I would have to say
quite lazily on climate change and in
the olden days meaning perhaps about
five years ago you would at least have
had to haul someone on to the news to
verify that who seemed to know what he
or she was talking about but not anymore
now we can just call anything that is
disagreeable in the atmosphere or the
geosphere climate change and I think
that ultimately this backfires because
it starts to sound like propaganda
that's because it is if it's not backed
by any causal science it starts to sound
like background noise